and the very same network that patted
itself on the back for the journalism
they conducted throughout the Muller
investigation did more of that same
journalism last night here's CNN's
Anderson Cooper this is badgering White
House principal deputy press secretary
Hogan did Lee get an active wanted for
so long is for the presence would be
guilty if they had anything on him he'd
be indicted today he wasn't because they
don't have the evidence
did the president lie they have to put
up or shut up here Anderson they know
president lie I'm not no I'm not aware
of him lying he hasn't lied to me but
you feel bad they're scared I'll say
that your boss lied it just seems
nothing I just said don't know why we're
not work in that situation yep with me
now is Hogan get Lee Kogan you know I
would love watch on TV you know I said
let me tell it let's talk about your
boss Anderson let's talk about mr.
soccer right have a conversation because
they saw this little gotcha game we can
go two ways with it everybody's
everybody feels what because they're
their hosts on a cable network that the
table can be turned on all of us well
believe me I'm always in the crosshairs
right but but what was that like being
on set I mean it was one hit after the
other he's obviously focusing on the ten
obstructive acts sure we'll listen first
of all I'm not going to take a lecture
on truth-telling from anybody in the
mainstream media who has been lying
about this president for the last two
years telling the American people that
Donald Trump committed treason which is
a crime punishable about punishable by
death as you well know what you didn't
play in that clip was after he said that
I told him you have a panelist a panel
full of liars every night on this show
the point is for me to sit there with
CNN and listen to them who they wanted
this to be trashed so badly so many in
the media did and it I understand why
they don't drop it
because if they did they'd be admitting
the fact that the last two years of
their life was a complete and total
waste
Mitt Romney tonight released a statement
I'm sickened at the extent and
pervasiveness of dishonesty and
misdirection by individuals in the
highest office
and including the President and he went
on to say reading the report is a
sobering revelation of how far we have
strayed from the aspirations and
principles of the founders what do you
think about old Mitt Romney No
I'll tell you what's sobering is the
fact that someone like Mitt Romney would
join in with the the the chorus of
people who refuse to acknowledge the
fact that after you know thirty five
million dollars and 1.4 million
documents and countless hours of
testimony the president being an open
book allowing all of this to be put
forth public not asking for redactions
not meddling at all not firing anybody
allowing this to go forward that he
would join with the democrats and say we
want more i am telling you right now
this isn't moving the goal posts over
these people this is changing stadiums
now we're in a whole nother ballgame
here you could let the democrats work in
the white house give them all top-secret
security clearances let them stay in the
oval all day and sleep in the residence
and it still wouldn't be enough for them
they'd want something else maybe he did
this I don't remember Anderson Cooper
getting Susan Rice across the table from
him and I said why don't you go out to
all these Sunday shows and say that the
the Benghazi attack was started by some
anti-islamic video why'd you do that
like maybe he did it I'm forgetting it
but I don't I don't remember the same
ferocity of the criticism look you've
worked with the president for some time
now I know I'm quite well well he's
tough like he's he can be tough but he's
also funny and try but he's demanding
and I never I never am rattled by a
demanding boss because it's someone who
wants to hold the bar high absolutely
and I know he wants to succeed and he
was frustrated we all know that cuz he
said it publicly that they were going
after him so he said I'm blanked you
know after and he was really angry and I
think he probably told a lot of people a
lot of things he's really angry what
does that tell you about him and did he
ever tell you or anyone you know to go
out and tell an untruth absolutely not
I've never had a conversation with like
with him like that at all and let's be
honest any red-blooded American who was
falsely accused of a crime for two plus
years would probably be a little upset
about it especially when you knew the
fact that you had done nothing
no collusion no obstruction a complete
and total exoneration and they pushed
this lie and I had some numbers I was
looking at since May of 2017 the New
York Times has put out 1156 stories
about Muller CNN one thousand nine
sixty-five and MSNBC tops more than four
thousand they just can't get past the
fact they didn't get what they wanted
here they wanted a conviction they
wanted a smoking gun they have no
evidence and like I said last night if
Bob Muller a Special Counsel had
anything on the president he would have
indicted prosecutors prosecute but they
only prosecute if they had the evidence
he didn't and this is a complete and
total exoneration of his present this
was shift today on MSNBC let's watch an
impeachment proceeding cannot be
successful if one party decides they're
more loyal to their party or to the
person of the president than they are to
the Constitution in the country the GOP
has no independence from this president
it has made itself effectively a cult of
trumps personality the President of the
United States is too weak to confront
Vladimir Putin when it comes to election
interference and as long as they
interfere on his side he may even be
grateful I recall him being upset that
it all happened under Obama's watch but
you can react to any of that apparently
the president's just too it's still
still colluding with Russia well I heard
him on the same network of the clip you
played just earlier with with someone
else at CNN and the point was he said he
didn't feel as though it was time to
move forward on impeachment because they
didn't have overwhelming and
demonstrable evidence when it wait a
minute you've literally been telling
America that you had the evidence you've
seen the collusion you know it exists no
one pushes up and follows up and says
hey where's the president yeah are you
are you gonna step down for lying about
someone for two years are you gonna be
held accountable at all it's absolutely
disgraced Staedtler your friend over at
CNN is tweeting out thirty nine days
since a formal press briefing not a sign
of a confident White House when's the
next press briefing I don't know it
looked a president makes those calls all
the time he lets us know if he wants us
to go out but we gaggle multiple times a
day we go out with the most they're
gonna get their faces on TV
we have to pad their own careers and get
some time to contracts with networks we
know how it works but we're not we're
not in the business of making them
famous all right Hogan thanks so much
for being out with I really appreciate
it